It may interest you to note that
the projects you have been doing in
this class are base on
cutting edge research.
Under just a few years back, all
conventional models of solving problems
on the Ravens test first extracted
popular presentations from the figures
and then ran engines on
these presentations.
Does them extract
a transformation from A to B
in the form of a semantic
network shown here.
And similarly they made,
extracted transformation,
from C to 5, through
the symmetric network shown here.
They would then compare these two
symmetric networks and decide whether or
not A is to B, is similar to C is to 5.
You may have done something
similar in your early projects.
But in 2012, here at Georgia Tech was
able to write a computer program that
used only analogical representations
without extracting any representations
and yet were able to solve problems on
the Ravens Progressive Matrices test.
It used only affine and
set transformations over
the analogical representations.
So as an example, it would compare A and
B by saying there is a set
transformation, this particular
dot is no longer there.
And there is affine transformation,
in fact two affine transformations.
First, they made this square bigger and
second the cross
position of the square from inside
the circle to outside the circle.
It would find similar affine and
set transformations that
would relate C and 5.
That will compare the affine and
set transformations,
again without extracting any purpose for
presentations.
Little surprisingly,
program called Asti, or
A-S-T-I, was able to do quite
well on the Ravens test.
It solved 50 out of the 60
problems correctly.
Then in 2013, Keith McGregor,
again here at Georgia Tech,
wrote another computer program
that used a different kind of
analogical representation called
a fractal representation.
And he was able to show that
the fractal representation also enables
addressing problems on the Ravens
test with a good degree of accuracy.
It provided references both work and
Keith's work in the notes.